posez lui vos questions on vous trouve
l'info neal a l'air était bien connu à
sherbrooke
c'était un bon vivant c'est lui qui joue
de la batterie ici et c'était le père
d'une collègue dans l'équipe
monsieur a l'air est mort il ya deux ans
comme des millions de canadiens
ils avaient un compte facebook un jour
son compte est devenu commémoratif
comment facebook a su que neil a l'air
était décédé est ce que facebook peut
voir que le contenu plus actifs
on pourrait comprendre que facebook
veille départager les morts des vivants
parce que selon une étude dans 50 ans il
pourrait y avoir plus de comptes de
personnes décédées que de comptes de
personnes vivantes
rassurez vous facebook ne fait pas tout
seul c'est un membre de la famille de
stéphanie qui a transformé le compte de
monsieur halley rencontre commémoratif
avec une preuve de décès ça permet
aujourd'hui aux proches de se retrouver
autour d'une même page
autre option la famille aurait pu
demander à facebook de supprimer le
compte
dans les deux cas la famille n'y a pas
accès aux données privées de monsieur a
l'air comme ces messages personnels par
exemple alexandre plourde option
consommateurs
la messagerie lorsqu'une personne décède
fier aux produits du terroir aquitain
simplement parce que la loi a donné un
conseil faites la liste de vos comptes
numériques votre succession pourra au
moins les supprimer même si elle n'y a
pas accès vous pouvez aussi prendre les
devants mais décider maintenant ce qui
adviendra de votre page facebook
quand vous ne serez plus de ce monde
allez voir ici dans vos paramètres le
plein d'options
posez votre question on vous trouve
l'info par seulement